hi everyone its Charlie this is gonna be
my Game of Thrones Season eight episode
three Q&A video so here we go there were
so many questions about the mythology
about what's happening next about what
the shows doing with the big twist so I
tried to include as much of that as
possible in the video but I do have a
couple other bigger bonus videos planned
for later this week to follow up on that
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the Game
of Thrones videos I know we only have
three episodes left but then later this
summer we'll be talking about the game
of Thrones prequel series that's
supposed to premiere next year which is
called the long night I know last
night's episode was called the long
night but for right now they're just
referring to the prequel series as the
long night so it gets a little confusing
but don't worry we'll talk about that
after the finale there's a new round of
that HBO now giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video obviously careful
for spoilers through episode 3 if you
have not seen the episode yet so here we
go first question house people asks is
there any chance the night king could be
resurrected or recreated well he could
be recreated but there's really as far
as we know only one person who knows how
to do that and that's bran stark so it
depends on whether or not you think he
wants another night king they haven't
absolutely confirmed it but I think for
the most part they've killed off the
children of the forest I think that was
the idea of season 6 episode 5 when the
night king invaded the three-eyed Ravens
tree in there with the remaining
children of the force that were there
protecting him but unless there's some
that we don't know about they were
hiding out on the Isle of faces for all
intents and purposes the children of the
forest are gone on the TV show next
question fo asks can they still use
brand in their fight against Cersei he
can see everything he can warn them
about Kai burns device so you're talking
about the scorpions there's actually an
interesting thing that I saw in the
behind-the-scenes featurettes this week
if you've ever watched those featurettes
that they release like the game reveal
they'll do interviews with the actors if
you've noticed the last couple of them
have featured all them wearing very
summery looking outfits down on the
King's Landing sets in the behind the
scenes for episode 3 you see brand
wearing a very summery looking outfit on
that King's Landing set so it implies
that they're gonna take brand with them
when they go to King's Landing to go get
Cersei it does
absolutely confirmed that he's going
down they could be tricking us just
putting him in a costume like that on
that King's Landing set because a lot of
other interviews are happening in this
type of space but it definitely seems
like he's gonna go down there because
he's still alive and then even people
have pointed out that there must always
be a stark in Winterfell they can still
avoid trampling on that if Sansa stays
in Winterfell but I think we'll find out
pretty soon during episode four who's
going down to King's Landing and who's
not going down next question Alec asks
do you think that it's possible that
bran was working into Arya near the end
of the episode what else could he have
been doing while Theon was protecting
him so you're just asking about why he
just checked out for most of the fight
and we didn't see what he was doing he
just seemed like he was working into
something the first time he did it he
was using the Ravens to find out what
was going on with the night king during
the battle but then later in the episode
he was still warding you didn't see any
Ravens anywhere else so my assumption
just based on what the show was telling
us in this moment is is that he knew
what was going to happen because he was
using his green site to try and see into
the future so in this moment he was
looking at the night King like when he
looks down at the Night Kings chest then
back up at his face he was looking at
the weak spot where he knew the Arya
would have to kill him
so unless the producers come out and say
something different I'm just assuming
that he was using his abilities to see
into the future next question and
Christina asks will bran be normal now
that the night king is dead the
three-eyed Raven is linked to the
existence than I can write so if that's
the case will bran be free to be the
Lord of Winterfell and perhaps still a
warg that's an interesting question but
I think for now unless they tell us
something radically different at the
beginning of episode 4 I think that it's
the exact same for bran going forward he
still has all that power you have to
remember based on his explanation he's
the human repository of all knowledge of
the world so it'll be really interesting
to see why they would take him to King's
Landing and how they're gonna use his
abilities in the last couple of episodes
everyone's been making jokes about the
creepy stairs that he gives everyone
that he wheels by in the Winterfell
courtyard but more than anyone he has
been giving Tyrion really long stairs so
I think that it implies that he's gonna
be down in King's Landing knowing that
Tyrion is gonna do something really
crazy just in terms of Winterfell I
think that Santa will continue to be the
lady of Winterfell in the sort of warden
s of the north and continue to see the
reconstruction of Winterfell because
most of it
destroyed during the battle next
question Joseph asks would really love
to know how Aria got that close to the
night king in the last scene in order to
attack and eventually kill him did she
use the face of one of the Dead I know
she's really sneaky but it seems almost
impossible a living person to get past
that many White Walkers unless they're
disguised as one there were a lot of
questions about this how sneaky is she
why was she able to get past all those
white Walker generals and get that close
to the night king the only real
complaints that I had about that final
scene were mostly the execution you know
the fact that Jon Snow really didn't do
anything to contribute to that or
Daenerys and George are Martin has kind
of been setting that bump to the
background as this essaouira high
princess Prince who was promised
prophecy like Melisandre I think that
you both have a role to play but when it
was all said and done in the moment it
didn't seem like they had much of a role
to play Miguel Zepeda said something
really interesting in the behind the
scenes for the way they filmed this
scene and he said that the producers Dan
and Dave let the people filming it he's
the director the DP break every rule
that the show has about the way they
film things he was mostly referring to
the style of filming like they filmed it
in slow motion Game of Thrones as a show
just does not use a lot of slow motion
they also used a very different kind of
musical soundtrack so Ramin Djawadi used
piano during the score in the only other
time he's used a lot of piano in a game
of Thrones song was during the light of
the seven song which was the song that
played over the scene of Cersei blowing
up the Crypt during season six episode
10 so on a production level it was them
just trying to make it seem like a
special a moment as possible and when
you look at the behind the scenes she's
literally flying through the air look at
how high up she is in this rig so that
they could pull that shot off so of
course even if you think that Aria has
crazy faces person skills she can't jump
that high in real life so yes it is very
unrealistic within the context of what
her abilities are but on the most basic
of level what they're trying to say is
is that the night King was so focused in
this moment with bran that the other
White Walkers were just sort of
hypnotized by what was going on in the
moment in this moment of arias sneaking
past them to kill the night king was
what all of her faceless person training
was building up to and in the books
George our Martin has talked a lot about
how important aria is to the endgame so
I do think that in the books are
we'll still be the one to land the
killing blow on the night King even
though in George RR Martin's book
version of what this scene winds up
being will be way way different like Jon
Snow and Daenerys will probably have a
much bigger role in the way this all
goes down but what I'll do is is because
there's a much larger conversation about
that and why George R Martin's version
will be very similar but a little bit
different will be a video later this
week about azor Ahai the prince and
princess who was promised in the
fulfillment of that prophecy because
this late in the show I don't think the
show is going to tie up all the loose
ends that you're expecting it to next
question Josh Drummond asks what's the
deal with Melisandre sending so you're
asking about her just walking out into
the fields and taking off her necklace
and turning almost into dust there was a
bunch of dust coming off her when she
fell down I think that's just another
payoff for what she said about how beric
Dondarrion went out the Lord of Light
brought him back for a reason that
reason is fulfilled now that he no
longer has a purpose he can die she felt
like the Lord of Light told her in
visions that she had a role to play
she felt like she fulfilled that purpose
the long night is over the threat is
gone so she can finally die and remember
she is really really old that glamour
term worked really really well I love it
so much that they did the extra special
effects to make her old in that moment
to it just like an extra nice little
touch on her ending but like she told
Davos there's no need to kill me because
I'll be dead before dawn all of her
prophecies are starting to come true now
what about the other prophecies about
the prince and princess who was promised
like I said Melisandre's prophecies
starting to come true so I still think
there's a fulfillment of azor Ahai
that's a little bit different from what
people were expecting next question Loki
of Asgard asks what do you think about
ghost is he still alive yes we saw a
ghost in the episode 4 trailer video we
also saw both of Daenerys dragons so
regal and drogon are also still alive
there were a lot of people that were
confused about who is alive who is dead
at the end of the episode they'll answer
most of those questions at the beginning
of episode 4 because they have to burn
all those bodies so you see that scene
of everyone standing out there and I'm
having a sort of memorial to all the
people that bell especially the Dothraki
may they rest in peace
next question Tinashe asks how will the
show deal with all the drawings they
have been showing us they didn't explain
that before killing the night king so
assume you're talking about
all the children of the forest drawings
the symbols that the White Walkers in
the night King had been making this
whole time the way they explained some
of the symbols especially at the
beginning of the series and the spiral
symbol that the knight King kept making
is that it was really just a perversion
of the children of the forest symbol
that they used to invoke the magic to
create the night King it'd be like
someone going up to a Christian turning
a cross upside-down and saying I am
against everything that you stand for
that's basically what the knight King is
saying every time he makes a symbol like
this next question James D s no one's
discussing the Nike possibly being a
Targaryen as he survived Dragon Fire
there were a lot of questions I tried to
address this during my episode 3 video
he didn't survive the fire because he's
Targaryen it's just because he's so
powerful there's this idea behind the
show that everyone's been drawing this
power from the same source like all
these different gods they've been
worshipping are just different aspects
of the same God like the whole idea of
the many-faced God many faces but one
God the children of the forest used
their most powerful magic to create the
night king so it would stand to reason
that he would be impervious to almost
all kinds of magic save for the idea
that he could be uncreated with Valyrian
steel in the exact place where the
children of the forest stabbed him with
that dragon glass when they created him
next question Kathuria asks the origins
of the night king who was he and the
reason behind him coming after the
three-eyed raven was so a brain gave
that basic explainer he was trying to
kill bran to extinguish man and bran was
the repository of knowledge of all man
so he was gonna get rid of memories of
man first the Nike was created during
the time of the first men in their war
with the children of the forest so the
Andals had not come over there were no
Targaryens in Westeros yet it was just
the first men so he was a north man that
the children of the forest captured and
used to turn against his own brethren
there are a lot of rumors that he was a
stark of Winterfell
nobody has confirmed this George R
Martin has confirmed it yet but there's
some evidence pointing to the fact that
he could have been a stark of Winterfell
and the way the show explains it he's
always been the same night king whereas
there's been many many three-eyed Ravens
so one will become the three-eyed raven
he'll grow old then eventually another
one will come along he'll pass his
knowledge on to them and then that one
will pass his knowledge on to the next
three-eyed Ravens so on so forth until
you get to bran stark within the world
of Game of Thrones there are several
events in world history that sound like
their other versions of long nights and
night Kings coming people coming
together different azor Ahai figures
popping up predating the first long
night by a long long time there was a
very vast civilization in ET that rose
and fell long before the first long
night so there is a theory that there's
been many night kings in the past many
long nights that have come and gone many
differences or high figures but I'll
talk about that during my Azure 'hi
video later this week next question on
Keita asks what the hell was bran doing
all along so I think for the most part
he was just serving as bait like he said
he was just trying to bait the night
king into thinking that he was
vulnerable whereas most the time he was
working into the future to try and see
that everything would go down the way he
wanted it to I'm sure Isaac Hempstead
right is also probably gonna do a bunch
of interviews about this moment at
conventions in the next couple of years
so he'll probably talk a little bit more
about what was going on inside brands
head during this moment because we don't
really see it we just see him being
worked out
next question me Toole asks if the night
King is gone what about Danny's vision
and King's Landing where the roof is
gone and it's snowing and she's close to
the throne he has a lot of questions
about what the meaning of this vision is
if the night king isn't going to be down
there to cause any of this damage I
think the vision is still relevant to
what's happening in the last couple of
episodes but I think the metaphors are
just a little bit different from what
people are expecting I do think that
she's going to be forced to give up what
she loves I talked about it during the
jenny of old stones explainer that I did
last week genève old stones was a
commoner who fell in love with one of
the Targaryen heirs to the iron throne
he was forced to give up his crown in
order to be with her but in this case I
think the twist is is that Daenerys is
going to have to give up her quest for
the iron throne to be with Jon Snow so
we think a lot of the vision has just
tied up in the idea that she's going to
come close to her goal but she will not
actually reach it like she's reaching
out but she's not quite touching it but
I also think the Battle Damage is
something to do with the final battle at
King's Landing with Cersei so remember
there's still a couple episodes to go we
still have a huge episode 5 battle so
they could still blow up giant portions
of King's Landing during their fight
next question real Angelou asks who's
the original owner of Arya's dagger
there were so many theories about the
dagger after we first saw it if they
brought it back and then we
in samwell's book it was all about
Dragan stoned illyrians and the
Targaryens using dragonglass if you
would ask me this question last year my
theory was is that it actually at one
time had belonged to Rhaegar Targaryen
so just tracing it back from bran stark
and Arya Starks O'Brien hands it to Arya
Littlefinger gave it to brand what
happened during season one is is because
it's called the cat's paws dagger is
because it was the cat's paw who tried
to kill bran with it the cat's paw was
hired by Joffrey he gave him the dagger
but the dagger had belonged to Robert
because he'd won it in a bet from
Littlefinger in King's Landing but you
have to remember that there was a scene
that the TV show did not do where
Joffrey is sitting there the next
morning listen to people talk about what
happened to bran stark and through that
conversation he just comes to the
conclusion that it would be better to
get rid of him so if Joffrey stole it
from Robert Baratheon and Robert
Baratheon won it from Littlefinger how
did Littlefinger orchestrate events to
get it into Roberts Han and where did
Littlefinger get it from well the idea
is that because Rhaegar loved to put
rubies in his armour and in his things
like he had a rubies all over his
breastplate when he died at the Trident
rubies flew everywhere when Robert
Baratheon smashed him with his war
hammer at the Trident Rhaegar was a
Prince of Dragonstone Anna Targaryen
they would have had more access to
Valyrian steel either through their
money or just through their family
heirlooms than anyone else in Westeros
so it's possible that the dagger was
acquired during the sack of King's
Landing from Rhaegar things or at some
other point Littlefinger saw an
opportunity through Robert Baratheon
knowing that he would be going to
Winterfell so he engineered a situation
where the dagger would wind up in his
possession and then tried to push things
along and create as much chaos as
possible but a lot of what we know about
the dagger before it belonged to
Littlefinger in Robert Baratheon is
conjecture and just theories based on
hints that we get throughout the books
nobody's absolutely confirmed it thank
you so much for submitting questions I
know there's a billion more so I'll try
to address that in some specific bonus
videos later this week like I said
Maiasaura high video will probably be
the next one if there's any other really
big questions that you guys have or
bonus videos you want me to do before
episode 4 airs just let me know in the
comments below but congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last video
super thumpa Soros please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here for my
season 8 episode for
or video and click here for my episode 3
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight